what do you make of this uh bill and
melinda gates divorce are you following
that
that's a crazy story no i haven't but i
know if i say
that she's going to get a ridiculous
amount of money that she didn't earned
i'm going to be labeled a misogynist
of course she's going to get a
ridiculous amount of money yeah well
yeah
what do you mean why she's been a
partner
uh stop it what stop it stop what
just stop with this [ __ ] that like
dr dre's wife hanging out with them and
that's why he came up with the
headphones
he like i don't understand like what do
you talk to your wife about are you
sitting there going over plans and
blueprints
you're not it's all like you know you've
been working a lot lately
yeah which isn't even supportive don't
wait a minute
hey i am i am liberal when it comes to
this [ __ ] cause when britney spears got
divorced from that backup dancer
he should have got a tracksuit and a
laptop
okay those were all her songs and i'm
gonna say no but he supported her but
this has nothing to do then what you're
saying is this has nothing to do you
know what i love about bill gender oh
you know what i love about bill gates
probably i love that he has so much
[ __ ] money that even if she cuts him
in half
he's still got 15 million 15 billion
yeah yeah
yeah so he's still there yeah he can
enter that second part of his life
you know maybe wear an open shirt get
the convertible
to track something like you know get a
third of his age get like an 88 christ
little baron
no no get the ferrari california
you know the gt right you get the gt
with the top down you know yeah yeah
yeah and go attract some gold digger
that's gonna like you know build up your
ego do that for a while
do you think that's what he's gonna do
are these gonna start i think if you buy
that car that's what it comes to you
like there's a danger to buying that car
that big yell they see that big yellow
prancing pony and they just come out
they come up out of the manhole covers
all these gold diggers
like a zombie movie
you make a lot of money you can't buy a
car like that it
is a that is a gold digger magnet and
they are so good at it they can look and
tell if
it's rented or not they know where to
look for the sticker
i'm just saying predator behavior goes
both ways
but this sort of predator behavior does
not fit the narrative
i see i see yeah okay okay uh
of all those those white people branding
themselves as good people rather than
just trying to make money off the
suffering of others
who just all of these people were
sitting there acting like that like
they're not
like everybody is up in the head
you are if you really listen to your
inner monologue i thought that
stuck in traffic i actually had the
thought uncontrolled
selfish moment i wish covid killed more
people so i could get to the comedy
store
quicker jesus i thought i'm not i know
it's a wrong thought
right but you're admitting that you had
that i've wanted to kill and kill again
but i don't do it
i don't do it either that's the
difference between being on the outside
so you
think you know a buddy of mine
told me he watched this documentary on
uh the son of sam
and he was saying like dude you gotta
see it he didn't kill all those people
he had help
and i was like dude i'm not watching
this documentary he goes nah they proved
it
i go they did he goes yeah yeah they
proved it i go
how did they prove it they go well they
went in they asked david berkowitz they
asked him they go did you kill this guy
he's like yes did you kill this guy he's
like yes did you kill this guy he goes
no
he said no i go oh you mean the guy who
was talking to a dog that guy
that guy said that's your proof
i don't know